nous croyons les nations démocratiques
dépassé elles sont résolument modernes
nous y croyons impuissante face au
courant de la mondialisation ou leur
découvrant une souplesse et une
réactivité hors norme
elles sont capables de la maîtriser pour
en tirer le meilleur
[Musique]
si nous voulons sortir par le haut des
crises de la mondialisation qui se
multiplient ces dernières années et dont
le corps n'a virus c'est finalement le
dernier avatar nous avons besoin d'états
nations fort
[Musique]
nous avons des approches parfois trop
caricatural sur la mondialisation c'est
dark et des discours qui considère qu'il
faut l'embrasser sans réserve et qu'il
faut même l'accompagner politiquement et
institutionnellement d'autres discours
nous explique qu'au contraire il faut
s'en protéger qu'il faut se replier sur
nous-mêmes comme le village d'astérix et
l'idée que je défends dans le livre
c'est au contraire qu' il faut la
maîtriser et que ça suppose une
intervention politique vigoureuse des
politiques publiques et que l'état
nation joue un rôle des cluses
absolument incontournable
[Musique]
la crise économique et financière de
2008 dont nous payons encore aujourd'hui
la facture puisque même si des mesures
très fortes ont été prises pour sauver
les économies en particulier grâce à
l'action des banques centrales les
effets sur la société notamment sur les
sociétés occidentales ont été durables
et douloureux j'ai de nombreuses sources
d'inspiration évidemment fernand braudel
m'inspire énormément sa capacité à
réfléchir à ce qu'est le temps de la
politique par rapport à ce qu'est le
temps de l'économie à articuler sa
réflexion à différentes échelles aussi
je pense que c'est un auteur extrêmement
important pour moi je suis aussi très
influencé par le philosophe américain
michael walser qui est un philosophe
républicain nous devons inventer un
nouveau mode de collaboration si j'ose
dire entre un capitalisme de plus en
plus mondialisé et une démocratie qui
persistent à se vivre et à s'exercer
dans les états nations
[Musique]